As we saw in the first of
the last three quizzes,
deciding if a system has a solution
at all comes down to looking for
equations of the form 0 = k for
some non-0 k.
If we ever find one then we know
that the system has no solution.
But deciding whether a system
has a unique solution or
infinitely many solutions
is much trickier.
As we saw, it's not enough to just
count the number of equations or
look for an equation of the form 0 = 0.
Instead, deciding whether
there's a unique solution or
not comes down to seeing if in
triangular form we end up with
every variable as a leading variable,
which we also called pivot variables.
If every variable is a pivot variable,
then there's a unique solution.
Otherwise, we're going to have
infinitely many solutions.
In fact, each non-pivot, or
free variable, will be an independent
parameter in our solution set.
This means that the dimension
of our solution set
will be equal to the number
of free variables we have.
If there's one free variable,
the solution set will be a line.
If there are two free variables,
the solution set will be a plane.
As we move into higher dimensions,
this pattern will continue.